[Musique]
alors qu'ici cuisine à l'inspiration
sans recette au feeling pas mal de monde
si au contraire cuisine en suivant une
recette qui vient votre enfance votre
famille ou en suivant un livre ok pas
mal donc il ya un peu des deux alors à
tous ceux qui cuisinent dans
l'inspiration bravo vous avez sûrement
un vrai don de chimiste est bon je sais
pas goûté vos créations je m'avance un
peu peut-être et à tous les autres
une grande majorité parfois qui suivent
une recette que vous connaissez par
coeur toutes mes félicitations vous avez
appris où vous avez trouvé tout seul où
on vous a appris s'cusez moi qu'il ya
une méthode pour produire un repas
comestibles voire même délicieux et
cette méthode c'est la recette qui a été
pré testée pour vous par des chefs des
père et mère de famille des amateurs
d'un bon repas et puis amélioré au fil
des ans
et si maintenant je vous demande qui ici
à une méthode pour mémoriser qui a une
méthode pour se concentrer qui a une
méthode pour réfléchir résoudre des
problèmes qui a une méthode pour gérer
ses émotions pour comprendre les autres
pour se faire comprendre des autres qui
a une méthode pour aller chercher un
souvenir bien enfoui au fond de sa tête
et si l inverse je vous demande qui fait
tout ça au feeling la grande majorité
d'entre vous fait ça de façon un peu
intuitive et très peu mais quelques-uns
font ça en ayant une méthode une recette
et 2 fait quand on n'a pas de recette
le résultat n'est pas toujours à la
hauteur de nos attentes on n'a pas du
tout réussi à retenir le prénom des
trois personnes hyper importante
il convient de présenter dans le couloir
ou alors on n'a rien retenu de la
réunion de ce matin et là pas de bol
faut faire un petit compte rendu
al'inverse non à cette même réunion on a
dit plein de choses des gens ont rien
compris
et puis tout au long de la journée ont
subi
aux émotions sais pas pourquoi ils sont
là on comprend rien ou alors on n'arrive
pas à se concentrer on est distrait
c'est l'enfer et à la fin de la journée
on va en conclure qu'on est nul qu on
n'est pas à la hauteur
alors qu'en fait on n'a pas la recette
on ne sait pas comment faire si
maintenant je vous demande si ce soit
pas plus intéressant d'utiliser notre
cerveau comme quand on fait de la
cuisine
si on l'utilisé de façon un peu plus
méthodique avec une recette si on
utilisait notre cerveau en comprenant un
petit peu mieux
juste ce qu'il faut pour améliorer nos
performances pour éviter de gâcher de
l'énergie dans tous les sens et c'est ça
que je transmette ce soir en comprenant
mieux notre cerveau nous avons la
possibilité d'obtenir un résultat
attendu comme une recette bien rodée qui
nous donne satisfaction à tous les coups
et la grande nouvelle c'est qu'on a les
connaissances modeste mais suffisamment
utile est applicable pour tous pour que
chacun apprenne le fonctionnement de son
cerveau le comprennent et puis améliore
toutes ses tâches quotidiennes
même les plus petites d'entre elles ses
connaissances
une méthode c'est la métacognition la
métacognition c'est la capacité que nous
avons à réfléchir sur nos propres
processus mentaux la métacognition c'est
comprendre nos propres fonctionnement et
en comprenant notre fonctionnement nous
allons mieux utiliser notre cerveau un
peu comme un sportif qui connaît bien
son corps connaît ses limites et qui
sait ce dont il a besoin pour couvrir
son marathon alors il ya pas mal
d'études peut-être que ça va parler à
certains ici qui montre qu'un étudiant à
qui on a appris comment apprendre à qui
on a appris la métacognition comment
utiliser son cerveau aura de meilleurs
résultats scolaires qu'un étudiant qui
n'a pas appris tout ça donc c'est
vraiment une recette formidable la
métacognition pour améliorer
l'apprentissage et pour aider les
enfants les adultes aussi à mieux
apprendre
si je prends l'exemple de la
mémorisation la mémorisation ça fait des
années qu'on connaît les stratégies pour
l'améliorer
ou pour céder la mémorisation
c'est une histoire de mettre des
informations en mémoire et cette mémoire
elle est très limité elle est vraiment
très limités au moment de mettre de
nouvelles informations
à l'intérieur une fois qu'on a bien
appris qu'on a tous retenu la mémoire à
long terme n'y a plus de limites
mais au moment de l'apprentissage c'est
un peu compliqué si on sait tout de
suite à ce moment là que cette mémoire à
court terme est limité qu'on ne peut pas
retenir un trop grand nombre
d'informations en même temps qu'on ne
peut pas manipuler trop d'informations
en même temps on essaiera juste pas et
on évitera de se mettre en échec
si en plus on connaît les quelques
stratégies qui nous permettent
d'améliorer notre mémoire
là c'est bingo on va se mettre en
situation de réussite tout de suite
alors il ya un autre levier incroyable
qui nous permet de booster nos
performances
peut-être une autre méthode potentiel
que nous connaissons tous mais que nous
maîtrisons vraiment très mal à ma
connaissance ce sont les émotions les
émotions pour la recherche actuelle ce
sont des états biologique qui nous
signale quelque chose sur notre monde
interne ou sur le monde externe
ce sont des indicateurs que quelque
chose va mériter notre attention je vous
invite peut-être chez vous ici à essayer
de chercher pourquoi vous ressentez les
émotions vous ressentez qu'est ce qui
cause chacune de ses émotions
pourquoi votre cerveau vous invite à
faire attention à cette cause
vous êtes en colère qu'est-ce qui mérite
à ce point là votre attention que ça
vous met dans cet état vous êtes triste
pourquoi cette méta cognition de nos
émotions comprendre nos émotions
ça va être aussi un excellent début pour
les réguler
mais on peut aller un peu plus loin que
cette compréhension tous nos
fonctionnements cognitif nos
performances cognitives dépend de nos
états émotionnels
par exemple un peu de stress peut
vraiment améliorer nos performances en
examen c'est un peu le cas on peut
peut-être réfléchir un peu mieux on peut
raisonner peut-être
peu plus fort on peut mémoriser on peut
se concentrer peut-être un peu mieux
aussi
évidemment le stress quotidien le stress
du travail le stress chronique c'est
très délétère et ça empêche plutôt la
bonne performance mais là on peut
imaginer déclencher soi-même un tout
petit peu de stress juste ce qu'il faut
à volonté pour améliorer nos
performances
ce serait pas mal alors je vais être un
petit peu provocatrice on sait que la
psychologie humaine ce n'est pas juste
une question d'action et de réaction
seulement à l'heure actuelle dans nos
sociétés les émotions ne sont pas du
tout considérés comme bienvenue
ni même intéressante et encore moins
utiles est ce qu'on ne peut pas se
servir de ses émotions en les comprenant
mieux et en les utilisant pour booster
nos performances je reprends l'exemple
de la mémorisation la mémorisation je
disais c'est une question de répétition
d'informations nouvelles une question de
répétition utile c'est-à-dire qu'une
nouvelle information on va l'utiliser
et puis la répétition de cette
utilisation va faire que ça va passer
dans notre mémoire à long terme qu'on va
s'en souvenir
il ya certains événements certaines
informations qui passent directement
dans cette mémoire à long terme qui vont
directement sans créé pour la vie
entière
c'est le cas des événements
traumatisants
hélas très négatif mais c'est aussi le
cas des événements personnels assez fort
exceptionnel unique joyeux et ceux là
sont plutôt positifs on peut donc se
dire si j'arrive à déclencher cette
émotion forte peut-être que j'arriverai
derrière à mémoriser en un coup en une
seule fois les informations pertinentes
que j'essaye de retenir
alors évidemment je prône pas du tout de
traumatiser toute la population mais
avec une émotion positive
c'est vraiment possible et là je vous
laisse imaginer un peu la puissance de
ce mode de mémorisation
c'est quand même assez phénoménal en une
fois on retient tout pas de répétition
finalement comprendre nos émotions et
les connaître connaître les causes de
ces émotions va nous permettre de les
déclencher
pour permettre d'améliorer nos
performances cognitives de la même façon
comprendre et connaître nos fonctions
cognitives avoir une bonne métacognition
nous permettra de les améliorer
et donc là il n'y a pas besoin de
matériel il n'y a pas besoin d'outils ya
pas besoin de petites pilules qui a
juste besoin d'une bonne connaissance de
soi une bonne connaissance de cette
recette la bonne métacognition merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]